celebrity attorney michael avenatti
tells CBS News he is nervous and scared
about the possibility of going to prison
but denies he did anything wrong
avenatti is charged in new york with
attempting to extort tens of millions of
dollars from nike he is also charged
with bank and wire fraud in California
Jericka Duncan spoke with him in an
interview you will see only on CBS this
morning
Jericka good morning good morning he
wanted to get his side out now if
convicted both cases in both cases
Michael avenatti could face up to nearly
100 years in prison so we sat down with
him less than a day after he was
released on $300,000 bond he maintains
his innocent innocence and told us he
believes he'll be exonerated prosecutors
are saying that you committed extortion
that you committed wire fraud and bank
fraud in California did you try to
extort nike for millions of dollars no
and any suggestion is absolutely absurd
Nike knew from the very first moment
that I had any contact with Nike that I
was insisting that the truth about what
Nike had done be disclosed to federal
prosecutors and investigators what is
the truth the truth is for years Nike
and its executives have been funneling
payments to amateur players high school
players and to their handlers and family
members in an effort to get them to go
to colleges that were Nike colleges and
ultimately hopefully to the NBA so they
could sign a shoe deal with Nike but
federal prosecutors maintained a
different version of the truth avenatti
was not acting as an attorney a
suit-and-tie
doesn't mask the fact that at its core
this was an old-fashioned shakedown they
alleged Michael avenatti attempted to
use his platform to blackmail the
apparel giant the complaint does suggest
that you asked for up to twenty million
dollars 1.5 for your client and at least
20 million dollars and that you
requested you be retained to do an
internal investigation and that if not
you and they hired someone else you
stand to make more money yeah I I'm not
gonna get into the specifics of this but
what I will say is the way this has been
framed is not accurate it's just not
accurate and in fact from the very first
moment that we had any meeting with Nike
we made it clear that under no
circumstances would we participate in
anything that did not require full
disclosure to investigators and the
federal government what about the case
in California you've been charged with
wire fraud bank fraud there were
comments you know in that complaint
saying that you tried to embezzle or you
did in bezel one point six million
dollars from a client you represented
the client who is accusing me of
embezzlement is currently on felony
probation in California you know what he
was convicted of multiple counts of
obtaining money under false pretenses it
turns out and I didn't know this at the
time that he has an extensive criminal
background and rap sheet associated with
his conduct
so again nowhere does that appear in the
complaint so there's gonna be a lot of
evidence there's gonna be a lot of facts
that have come going to come to light
you're facing if convicted on all of
these charges up to the rest of your
life in prison
are you nervous well of course I'm
nervous are you are you scared are you
concerned I mean tell us I guess as
someone who again has a history of
representing people and now you're on
the other side facing some serious
charges I am nervous I'm concerned I'm
scared but you also seem confident I am
confident because I believe the facts
are on my side in a statement Nike tells
CBS News when it became aware of a
vanadis quote plans to extort the
company it immediately reported it along
with information he shared to federal
prosecutors Nike says it has been
cooperating with the government's
investigation into NCAA basketball for
over a year and encourages avenatti to
share any information he believes he has
with the government
in a statement the NCAA said it will
quote always welcome and first any first
hand credible lawfully obtained and
disclosed information of NCAA rules and
violations it was interesting when Ricky
Kleeman was here yesterday she said it
was the charges for out of California
yeah attention would be the most serious
for him to say exactly in fact no battle
we're talking up to a hundred years in
prison so I think just his connections
to other stories that we've covered and
now he's on the other side is what makes
this so fascinating a lot of twists this
morning it's pretty defiant still jurika
confident as as he as you could fall
though he's really got an answer for
everything he did but the prosecutors
also have documents for everything they
have document for video recording audio
recordings so we will continue to follow
this absolutely thanks luxury